take a look at this unusual electronic
circuit board using this criminals
hacked seven ATMs in maau how did they
do that typically the crooks physically
crack an ATM to connect to it or steal
the safe with money or they use skimmers
special pads on the keypad and card
reader to copy the card information and
pin code but if you know how the ATM is
set up inside you can get by without
Brute Force the thieves used a rigid and
long green circuit board that they put
in the slot for ATM cards this board
could reach special contacts deep inside
the ATM and install a virus on it soon
after being hacked the ATMs begin to
record the cards and pins entered by
customers within days the hackers would
return to collect the stolen card
numbers and pins to make clones of the
users's cards but sometimes instead of
Ingenuity the crooks have to use an
excavator